And I really believe
that business is done human to human.
And it's about bringing humans together.
And because the community is people,
all you need to do really is listen
to the people in the community
and understand their needs.
Orlie Gruper,
thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Good morning.
Thank you for having me.
It's a pleasure and an honor
to have you here.
Executive director of EcoMotion.
The whole smart mobility space
is you know, fascinating.
There's so many advancements
and there's so many things
that are happening
that I can't even keep track.
And when I think about,
you know, where we're headed
in the next five or 10 years,
I'm incredibly excited.
You know, before we even talk about
your journey and who you are,
tell me a little bit about
what is smart mobility
and why is it something
that is so fascinating to you?
Wow.
It's my favorite topic.
So, smart mobility
is anything that is smarter,
greener, more efficient,
better save more money or
also just improve I guess,
something that is smarter than before.
If you look at mobility until now,
mobility used by vehicle,
now we're starting to see
that metro in Tel Aviv
and micro-mobility and bubble,
which is Via technologies
and all these other things.
So, we're right now seeing this
whole new revolution that is coming.
And basically I look at this revolution
kind of like we had
the Industrial Revolution, and then
we had the telecom revolution.
And what I love about the telecom
revolution, this is what I compare it
with in the mobility world is that
when we had the whole
telecommunication era
that had a lot of investment and a lot of
developing of technologies in this field,
a lot of money was thrown in.
In the end, we haven't seen, like we,
we didn't even understand
where we're going to.
And we didn't understand that we're
all end up with a flat screen. Right?
It's something
that no one thinks still happening
and this is like
a very given thing to us these days.
So, mobility for me is the same thing.
There's right now a lot of investment,
a lot of improvements.
A lot of people are working on it
from a lot of different angles.
We have no idea what [--],
but for sure it's going to be
a whole new, exciting era for us.
I think that is such an interesting
analogy, this flat screen analogy.
Now, when I'm thinking back
to when I was a kid, you know,
we're talking about 2004, 2005.
And we're looking at all these
advancements with the telecommunications.
Nobody really knew that in 2006,
Steve Jobs was going to go on stage
and show the flat iPhone,
the touch screen, and really create
a whole revolution in that sense.
And I think it's just inspiring
to think that we don't really know
what this iPhone representation
is going to be in the smart mobility space
moving forwards.
But Orlie, take me back a little bit
about to your journey.
How do you even get started
with smart mobility?
What is that trigger and what have been
some of your experiences
within the space?
Well, today, you know,
I see that it's farther
than I thought in the beginning,
because I was always passionate about
old fashioned vehicles.
I wanted a motorcycle
since I can remember.
And at the age of 15,
and I really wanted one already
and I could have it.
At the age of 16,
I started getting lessons.
And my parents let me have a lesson,
but they wouldn't mind me first
like in the end.
So, it turns out
I had to found my own company.
And I founded
an electric motorcycle company.
But I guess, professionally, it started
in the Army, in the Air Force.
I was
exposed to the whole aviation world.
I was in the room operations
of an F-16 squad,
and then a commander of course.
And I love aviation
and everything it brought with it.
And how, you know, it's crazy,
but we really take for granted the thing
that we go into this
vehicle, even if it's a car,
we sit down and then we come out
on the other side
after, you know, just resting for a while.
And after the army,
I was recruited to operate
private aviation fleet.
So, I continued with this passion.
And I did my BA in business majored in IT
and then founded the Blitz Motors.
I sold my half six years ago.
They just IPO-ed last week,
which is really exciting.
Wow. Congratulations.
Yeah, it's amazing.
It's electric motorcycles, you know.
And every motorcycle that someone,
like got off the road, old school petrol
with the whole smoke coming out
type of motorcycle and putting on
a new electric green coagulant.
It's like, everyone sold is like
it was an amazing,
amazing experience for me.
And I think that's incredible.
Orlie, I have to ask about the founding
of the Blitz company
with electric motorcycles.
It has to be a little bit different
than starting another software company
or you know,
the typical startup that you see today
that is mainly software focused
with either BTC or B2B.
You're here selling literally vehicles
that have to be certified
to go on the street.
They have to be saved.
They have to provide some
good experience to their users.
Tell me a little bit about
this founding of the company
and some of the interesting challenges
that you had along the way.
Wow. So many challenges.
Well, I guess it started really
by understanding what is needed
and what exists, right?
Because when you're doing a startup,
it doesn't matter what you do.
It's okay if you start searching
and you see that other things exist,
which are the same,
we're all on the same market.
It's okay. It means, there is a market.
But you need to see how you do it better
and how offer something
that they don't offer, right?
Right.
So, in motorcycles,
I mean it was, I saw that there's
a very high power but super expensive one
and not expensive ones,
but not at all meeting the requirements
of the Israeli rider, right?
They want to be
on the road, they're into power.
And then I went out looking for one
and we couldn't really find one.
So, we found different manufacturers
that created different parts
and found an assembler
that assembled everything
under our brand and created this vehicle,
two-wheel vehicle that
was at the same price
of petrol vehicles on the market.
But still, you were saving
from day one and you're high powered.
So, we gave people what they wanted.
And regarding challenges, so many.
Wow.
One time we meet, you know,
a manufacturer that will do it,
that will get on this adventure
second to get the Israeli government
on board with this
Ministry of Transportation
and then the Israeli Standard Institute,
and there's just that is a whole,
is a whole challenge.
We have a lot to go through
with easing bureaucracy
and then it was creating
a showroom in Tel Aviv,
and creating a whole garages network
all over Israel so they could
maintain the vehicle and then, you know,
creating a clientele and maintaining.
The thing I loved about the clients
is that they created their own bike club.
Like the electric motorcycle bikers club.
And really moving, yeah.
It really shows how
people were connected to our products.
I love that. Orlie,
I think this is a perfect segue
to the whole community scene.
Because your product,
your electric motorcycles created,
created some grassroots communities
that started as a result
of people buying into your product,
the mission and the experience.
But then you went and you intentionally
helped run and are still running,
i think the biggest
smart mobility community.
I think over 600 startups
are involved with community,
am I right?
Yeah. Over 600 start ups
and 12,000 community members.
Because startup can't really
grow within a void.
We started a community that brings
together all the relevant players.
So we have industry players, investors,
government entities, principalities,
academia, all in one.
And yeah, it's amazing.
EcoMotion started in 2012.
I used to be an entrepreneur.
As part of the community,
I started meetups, we're like 15 people.
And the guy they brought to talk
was talking about
innovative design more in 2012.
We weren't really talking about
the whole digitalization yet,
but understanding that that's the future
and how Israel
in this digitalization of mobility,
we talked about smarter mobility before
so, digitalization is a huge part of that
and how Israel now has
an advantage to do that.
And this community is amazing.
It's moving, actually.
Everyone is so engaged
in creating this better future
and really good people.
So, it's a great job.
I love that. Orlie,
tell me a little bit about
building a community
and running a community.
First in general,
the different challenges
and the things to keep in mind
when building a community,
but then specifically smart mobility.
And in a growing industry that is often
perhaps, misunderstood about its potential
or it's still if you can consider
pre-iPhone era, right,
in terms of the analogy
that we had before.
So, what are some of the challenges
and exhilarating factors
of running a community?
So, community is people.
That's what you need to understand.
And I really believe
that business is done
human to human, and it's about
bringing humans together.
And because the community is people,
all you need to do really is listen
to the people in the community
and understand their needs.
And then with the power
of the community and the quantity
to deliver those needs.
And these needs keeps changing
all the time.
So, you really needs to be on top of it.
We have on our team a community manager,
a partnerships manager.
We have an implementation manager.
And yet when we meet with startups,
the whole team meet with them.
It's not like one person job
because it's really important for me
that the whole team
can jump up of the trends,
the technology and the needs to hear
the startup all the time
and to try and pick up, you know,
in between all these meetings,
try and connect the dots.
So, when I just started at EcoMotion,
for example, I heard a lot of startups
saying, okay, now there are so many
investors out there
in the field of mobility, how do we know
who is relevant for us and so,
I heard this a lot of times
and then I was like,
okay, we need to do something.
So, ran into the kitchen
and started cooking a plan.
And we understood in the end that we want
to map all the investors out there.
And now we have like a digital map where
it goes according to the different sectors
as we see them.
So, you can see really the logos
into different categories
and you can filter by round.
So, you know
who's the relevant investor for you.
And when you click one you have a whole
all the information about this investor
and who is the person
to contact in the company.
So, we don't need to connect
and do intros and things like that.
The community can meet each other.
But it's a lot about
getting supporting tools for that
and facilitating those interactions.
That makes perfect sense. Yeah.
Tell me a little bit, though,
about investments in smart mobility.
Are they the same
as in a regular startup?
Is the due diligence process
is a little different?
What is the thinking process when you go
and evaluate a company that is perhaps
doing something that
the market is not yet accustomed to,
there maybe not even governmental support
or infrastructure yet,
but you're building a technology that
could potentially have a positive impact?
Well, I think
most governments of the world are now,
you're probably talking about autonomy.
So, I think most governments
in the world are now on board with this
in trying to understand how they create
regulation that is
supportive and not restraining.
Because it is really hard
to make up rules today
for something that, you know,
you only know the impact
in deployments in a few years.
So, regarding investments, I think
it's like many other fields.
The first thing
in investments is the team.
So, that's a really important one.
It doesn't matter what field you are.
The team is the first thing
people look at when they put money.
They put more money on the human
than they do on the technology.
Because in the end, the technology
will be made by humans creating it.
So, an investor wants to know that
the entrepreneurs will be able
to stand back up once they fall,
will be able to find solutions
when they're put on a brick wall
because they will, many times.
And they're frustrating in the domain.
But that's, I think, the main focus.
And there's many different
types of mobility when we look at it.
So, you have the whole
autonomous and connected world.
And in this, like last year or so,
there's a lot of talk about
level four and five being pushed back.
But level two, three here and now,
and there is so much technology
is needed already for these levels.
So, it shouldn't frighten anyone
wanting to go into this field
because there is so much more to be
created for that.
And that's the near future.
And also, I've seen really high
A and seed round investment.
So, a lot of companies
can really run for a while.
And the other things
are like mobility services.
So, it can be an app like Moovit.
Yeah. This is our mobility today.
And it could be
kick scooter shared platform.
Like we need to remember
Bird and Lime and all of those
were non-existent like five years ago.
Right?
It's like a whole new thing.
It's mind boggling
And it's awesome too
because we don't see our life
without it now.
And think how much
there is more to create on that
and how much
there is more to optimize.
And the mobility in different countries
is not at all the same.
Like Israel doesn't have
the great public transportation
where other countries do.
And there's advantages
and opportunities in each one of those.
Right.
Orlie, tell me a little bit about
the future of smart mobility
from your take
and from observing the work
of hundreds of startups.
What are some of the most exciting
advancements tangibly that we can expect
to see in our streets, on our phones,
satellites, whatever it may be?
How is our consumer behavior
expected to change realistically
over the next five or 10 years?
Wow. Five or 10 years, okay.
You're narrowing down
to more like the now.
Right.
What we are feeling the
five to 10 years in the shorter version,
shorter term is,
and I'm speaking this is too hard
for me because you know it's,
a lot have happened in the past 10 years.
But in this five to 10 years, I think
everything will become more seamless.
We're still buying tickets for stuff
that's not going to happen anymore.
You're just going to use things
and will be added to your bill kind of thing .
Where if you hop on a kickscooter
and then you get on a train
and you come off
and then you get on a bus then,
all of that ride will just be billed to you.
You don't have to deal with,
with too much payments.
In terms of logistics, I feel,
these five to 10 years,
from what we experience
in this whole corona era is like,
e-commerce, yeah, like craziness.
And this affects also logistics.
And I feel like logistics
is going to improve tremendously.
We're looking at instead of big trucks,
like picking things off the ship
and taking that into the city,
it's going to break down into smaller,
smaller packages and more urban like
logistics, something that is
more compatible with the city.
100%.
In whole, I feel this city is,
and most cities are
making more walkways and more bike lanes.
And Amsterdam was there
long ago before us.
But it really shows right now
that we're going back to this era
or forward to this era.
Regarding the autonomy,
then I think in time years
it'll be weird to drive
a whole way from our house
to the end destination.
I can't say, you know,
what level will be at and all of that.
I always say I'm not a prophet,
but I'm sure it will be weird.
You know what I mean?
I love that.
I love that distinction, by the way, Orlie.
Because you're not just saying that,
you know, it'll be common.
The fact that you're saying
that it'll be weird to drive the whole way
it implies that it's not just
that the people who ride the wave
are going to be the first consumers
that are going to jump into, you know,
like we have with Tesla's.
But you're saying that
our consumer behavior
is going to already shift in such a way
that it'll be odd to not have
some sort of autonomy
along your driving route.
Perhaps, some people
will have full autonomy.
But the average person,
it will be weird if they don't.
Orlie, unfortunately, you know,
20 minutes go by so quickly.
But I really want to thank you
for your time and for your generosity.
It goes by quick, right?
But I'd love to ask you
for the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
And I really wanted
to talk about gardening,
but we just didn't have time.
So, we'll keep that for the next episode.
Yeah.
Three words I use to describe myself.
Well, I guess I'm a child of light,
love and creation.
That's like the three words
that guide me in life.
This is what I feel
is the true meaning to everything.
Wonderful.
And what motivates me.
That sounds great.
Orlie, thank you very, very much.
This is a fantastic thing of inspiration.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
I can't wait to share this to the world.
Thank you.
Yes. Thank you.
Chow chow.